so the topic of this slideshow is going
to be meiosis and the process of
crossing over let's get started
so before we get started here's a fun
little phenomenon to think about the two
young girls in this picture here are
actually twins
and yet how can they be so different in
their skin tone appearance you know
pause the video read over the story try
to come up with an answer by the end of
this video hopefully you'll have a
better understanding than right now
so let's talk about the process of
meiosis you know cells that undergo
meiosis actually start diploid but by
the end finishes haploid cells so
meiosis is the process where the the
chromosome number of a cell is reduced
by half meiosis is the process that
creates gametes and in the picture the
orange thing that kind of looks like a
basketball this would be the female
gametes an egg cell and the other one
that looks kind of like a tadpole this
would be the nail gamete the sperm cell
meiosis makes the sperm and egg cells
now the end result of meiosis will be
four cells four haploid cells and each
of them genetically unique and so we
start to maybe uh understand maybe the
answer to that phenomenon from just a
moment ago let's go into more detail
so let's go through the cell cycle
involving meiosis so interphase in this
animation we're going to go through the
cell the cell is going to go through
interphase and it's going to start with
four pieces of DNA two black two red now
the black DNA is is maternal meaning
from one's mother and the red is
paternal meaning from one's father and
in this animation we're going to follow
six fictional genes in this cell and so
friends first of all Gene a is going to
be homozygous dominant to Capital
alleles Gene B is going to be
heterozygous one dominant one recessive
gene C is going to be homozygous
recessive two recessive alleles
Gene D homozygous dominant Gene e is
heterozygous and Gene f is heterozygous
now these six genes are fictional again
but in a real cell we have thousands
humans have about 21 22 000 uh genes
among our 46 units of DNA that we have
now this in this animation the cell is
going to have six genes a through F and
we're going to follow four uh four units
of DNA here
and so interphase is really the same as
before
and before we learned that there's a G1
stage where the cell will grow as it's
growing right now and ultimately create
additional organelles extra vacuoles and
lysosomes and such
and then comes the S stage or the
synthesis stage and this is where DNA
replication occurs watch what happens to
the DNA
a duplicate copy is made so even though
this cell started with four units of DNA
right now currently it has eight units
of DNA because it just duplicated it's
for copies to make eight
and then we come to the G2 stage where
the cell grows uh some more and so
interphase prior to meiosis is very
similar to interphase prior to mitosis
which we previously learned
so now let's go into the steps of
meiosis what we're going to see is that
there are two stages of meiosis meiosis
one and meiosis II so let's begin with
prophase one
some similarities to First Dimension
with mitosis
the nucleus is going to dissolve so in
my animation there goes the nucleus
dissolving
and then the chromatin the spaghetti
loose stringy linear versions of DNA are
going to coil and wind up into
chromosomes and so there we see that
just happen very very similar to what
happened in prophase of mitosis
well a couple additional events take
place now one being what is called
synapses the pairing of homologous
chromosomes you see the two chromosome
ones one in red one in black those are
homologous because it's the same
chromosome number same with the two
chromosome twos they're homologous so in
other words you could say the like
chromosome pairs with like chromosomes
spindle fibers pull the two chromosome
ones together and the two chromosome
twos together and this creates groupings
that we call tetrads there's a tetrad
involving the two chromosome twos there
is a tetrad involving the two chromosome
ones but why would this happen this sets
up what is called crossing over the
exchange of genetic material between
non-sister chromatids watch the
chromosomes of tetrad 1 3 2 1.
notice what just happened is portions of
maternal and paternal chromosomes broke
off and reattached with one another
let's watch that again in tetrad number
two
crossing over helps to recombine and mix
up the genetic material of the
chromosomes and you think about why is
this so important this helps to create a
lot of the genetic diversity that we
find within a species this helps to
ensure that every sperm and egg are
genetically unique
but now my question is well but why is
this so important why is having genetic
diversity within a species so important
and the answer is pretty straightforward
it helps to uh prevent the species from
Extinction if all organisms were the
same we would all be susceptible to the
same diseases and the same influences
that might harm one
let's go on into metaphase number one
and the tetrads are going to align along
the Equator of the cell spindle fibers
will pull them to the center the middle
line of the cell here and that's really
all there is to it
if we go into the next step
the next the next step being anaphase
number one
the tetrads are going to be separated
spindle fibers which I didn't picture in
this animation the spindle fibers will
separate and pull the chromosomes
of the tetrad some a couple of
chromosomes went to the left other
couple chromosomes went to the right
and so entire chromosomes if you notice
were pulled to opposite ends of each
cell
okay let's go to the next step telophase
one
so as we look at telophase number one
we're going to see that sometimes the
nucleus is going to regrow sometimes and
you'll see why in a moment why sometimes
it does not it's really no big deal
um cytokinesis is going to divide this
one cell into two cells there goes the
cytoplasm dividing into two cells
notice that each cell contains one of
the two homologous chromosomes right
there now look at my note at the bottom
it says currently eight units of DNA per
cell that's not correct anymore
currently now there are four units of
DNA per cell there's two chromosomes in
every cell but every chromosome has two
chromatids so two chromosomes times two
chromatids each is actually Four units
of DNA per cell
let's continue on
so now we start the next round of
meiosis this is really called meiosis II
it starts with prophase two that's a
Roman numeral by the way prophase two
not prophase 11 that's a Roman numeral
two
and at this point it really is just the
same as mitosis the nucleus is going to
redissolve so that's why sometimes it
doesn't even bother to reform during
telophase number one if the nucleus does
reform then it's just going to
redissolve during prophase number two
as we move on into the next step
The Next Step being metaphase number two
the remaining chromosomes are going to
be pulled to the equator line of the
cell there they go They're pulled to the
the middle line the equator line of the
cell right there
so as we move to anaphase number two
really this is the same as mitosis the
chromatids are going to be pulled
opposite ends of each cell now if we
bring up a picture of Gregor Mendel this
is where we're going to see the law of
segregation the allele see how the two a
alleles are kind of paired next to each
other the two B alleles are kind of
paired next to each other the alleles
are going to segregate from each other
there they go and eventually those two
cells will divide into four and this is
why we inherit only one allele for a
gene from each parent
okay looking at telophase number two
next it's really the same as mitosis
we're going to see cytokinesis is going
to divide these two cells into four
cells
then we're going to see the nucleus
begin to regrow the nucleus will regrow
in all four cells there
and then the chromatids which are still
coiled up the chromatids will unwind
into the loose linear versions of DNA
known as chromatin there they go look at
the note at the bottom where it says
currently four units of DNA per cell
that's not correct anymore
notice how every cell because of the
second round of dividing now only has
two units of DNA look at the node on top
we started this animation with the cell
with four units of DNA and now the cells
have two we've made haploid cells so the
end result for genetically unique
haploid cells if you pause the video and
browse over the ABCDEF alleles you're
going to notice that all four cells are
different from one another that's
because of the recombining process
that's because of crossing over which
took place way back in prophase number
prophase number one which we talked
about earlier
so this is starting to see the reason uh
for those two twin girls at the
beginning of this video
so if we come back to these twin girls
from earlier turns out there are three
alleles to help to determine the skin
tone of people allele a b and c now in
this table allele a b and c these are
real alleles real genes in the animation
I created a moment ago that went through
the stages of meiosis those alleles a
through F were completely fictional and
in this case subjectively I looked at
the gentleman in the picture of the
father and I kind of concluded that his
skin looks like the dark complexion that
would be his genotype and the mom in the
picture uh subjectively I I looked at
her and I thought that that's under the
very light so those are that's their
parents genotype
so subjectively to me the daughter the
the light-skinned daughter to me looked
very light and so how does this happen
well she gets uh we bring up Gregor
Mendel here and again the law of
segregation alleles segregate from each
other and so the light-skinned daughter
received two lowercase a alleles from
her parents she received two lowercase b
alleles from her parents
and she received the capital dominant
allele from her dad but a recessive
allele from her mom and so she has light
skin tone the other daughter with the
darker skin again subjectively to me
that looks like more intermediate
and so uh you can see the allele
combination for the Aging the allele
combination for the B Gene
and the allele combination for the C
Gene so even though we have uh twin
sisters here they they have very
different skin tones among them again
this was the law of segregation and also
a little bit of the crossing over that
we talked about earlier in this video
foreign so there you have a a
description of the stages of meiosis
here's a practice video you know pause
the video try to answer these questions
and I hope you found this video helpful
thanks for watching